sheep and goats lie dead under the
corrugated metal sheet that once formed
their shelter and where they sought
safety from the Flames she brought the
ones who survived water and feed there's
nothing for them to eat on the charred
Mountainside a few surviving yous are
ready to give birth and she worries
about how she will help them even there
was a small house there two storerooms I
had animal feed and here I had sheep and
goats it's all burned inside in the back
I had 60 chickens we've suffered huge
damage about 20 goats and 40 or 60 sheep
lost we've saved about 40 animals it's a
punishment meted out unfairly the wind
whipped fire picked Pathways that spared
some Farmers this century-old Vineyard
was only slightly cinched around the
edges this Olive Grove lost clusters of
trees here and there
the head of the alexandrupali Farmers
Cooperative is Fielding calls from
Farmers telling him terrible news and in
the midst of all this he remembers
growing up in these Hills
this forest was full of life Birds
animals deer flocks of sheep and goats
we're worried about what's coming
and it's not over this Village had its
second brush with fire in two days
I'm standing on the outskirts of the
village of gila in the neighborhood of
alexandropolis where small fires are
restarting in an area that was burned
about two days ago because there's so
much heat still in the ground and
because there is so much Tinder this
particular fire behind me is now burning
on small dry grasses and could easily
spread into the desiccated trees above
it eventually a firefighter did come
down with a hose but 10 meters away yet
more fires were being rekindled
villagers fought valiantly alongside the
fire service to save their homes but a
sudden violent wind brought the fire
front over the hill overwhelming
Defenders and kilo was ordered to
evacuate authorities are still
investigating the deaths of 18 people
near here thought to be migrants who may
have crossed the nearby Turkish border
hoping for a better life in Europe the
Greek government blamed their deaths on
what it called the murderous actions of
criminal traffickers this is the third
year in a row that some of these areas
have burned many people are worried that
in its struggle against a warming
climate Greece is in Retreat John
saropoulos Al Jazeera alexandropolis
foreign